The first thing you need to know about Lori is that normally she's not the kind of girl who does this sort of thing at all. She doesn't write to strangers. She doesn't do fan mail. But she's looking at-- you know the page in certain magazines where they have the little pictures of the people who write for the magazine? She was looking at that, and she saw the photo of this writer who she liked. The picture was blurry, but he had this intense look in his eye. And you could tell he was smart and cute, both at the same time.
关于洛莉，你需要知道的第一件事是，通常她根本不是那种会做这种事的人。她不会给陌生人写信，也不会写粉丝信。但她当时在看——你知道某些杂志里那种有供稿人小照片的页面吧？她在看那个，看到了她喜欢的一位作家的照片。照片很模糊，但他眼神中透着一股强烈的神采。你能看出他既聪明又可爱。
But I saw this picture, and I was like, that guy's my soul mate. And I know that's completely insane. But I knew that I could not not contact him because I would always regret it if I didn't.
但我看到那张照片时心想，那个男人是我的灵魂伴侣。我知道这完全是疯了。但我知道我不能不去联系他，因为如果我不这样做，我会永远后悔。
So I wrote this letter to the magazine, to him care of the magazine. And I made up a story. I said, I think that-- I know this is gonna sound really weird. But I saw your picture on the contributors page. And you look exactly like this guy that I met in the airport years ago. This is a complete lie.
于是我给杂志社写了这封信，托他们转交给他。我编了一个故事。我说，我想——我知道这听起来很奇怪。但我看到了供稿人页面上的照片。你看起来和我多年前在机场遇到的一个人一模一样。这完全是谎话。
Right.
对。
So I said, I was changing planes. And you were going into one gate, and I was going into another. And we struck up this conversation. And you were talking about how you wanted to become a writer.
所以我说，当时我正在换乘飞机。你走向一个登机口，我走向另一个。我们攀谈了起来。你谈到你想成为一名作家。
And I said, you know, I'm not sure if it's you. I know this sounds really strange, but if you remember this, let me know. And if it's not you, let me know also, just so that I know that it wasn't you.
我说，你知道，我不确定是不是你。我知道这听起来很奇怪，但如果你记得这件事，请告诉我。如果不是你，也请告诉我，这样我就知道那不是你了。
She figured that in the extremely unlikely event that they actually sort of got along and it led to something bigger, well, then she would admit the truth, and no harm done. Remember, she had never done this kind of scam before. She had no idea how complicated it could get.
她以为在极不可能的情况下，如果他们真的合得来，并且发展出什么，那么她就会承认真相，也就没有伤害了。记住，她以前从未玩过这种把戏。她根本不知道这会变得多么复杂。
So I don't hear from him, which I was relieved by, actually. After I sent the letter, I really regretted actually sending the letter because I was really sort of just embarrassed that I had done this. So then one day, like three months later, I get a call. And I was actually waiting for the cable guy. I'd been waiting for, like, three days for the cable guy. So I'm on the phone with the cable company, and they're saying, the guy in the field is going to call you any second on your call waiting. So we're gonna hang on with you while we contact him, and he's going to call you.
所以我没收到他的回音，事实上我对此感到如释重负。发出那封信后，我真的很后悔，因为我对自己做过的事感到尴尬。大约三个月后的某一天，我接到了一个电话。当时我正在等有线电视安装工。我已经等了大概三天了。我正在和有线电视公司通电话，他们说，外勤人员马上就会打你的呼叫等待。所以我们要在线等你联系他，他会打给你。
So then my call waiting beeps in. And I say, hello? And the person says, is this Lori? And I say yes. And the person says, I'm the guy. And I think he's the cable guy. So I say, where have you been? And he says, I know. I'm really sorry. I meant to contact you earlier. And this whole thing goes back and forth until I realize that he's not the cable guy. So I said, you're not the cable guy? And he says, no. I'm the guy from the airport.
接着我的呼叫等待响了。我说，你好？对方说，是洛莉吗？我说，是的。对方说，我是那个人。我以为他是安装工。我说，你跑哪去了？他说，我知道。我真的很抱歉。我本打算早点联系你的。整个对话反复进行了好一阵，直到我意识到他不是安装工。我说，你不是安装工？他说，不。我是机场那个人。
And I'm floored because I can't believe that he's calling me, that I'm actually on the phone with him, that I'm talking to this guy that I was momentarily obsessed with. And it's him. And he starts to tell me that he's really glad that he heard from me because, yes, he's the guy from the airport. And what a coincidence, he's coming to LA to do a story the next day, and can we see each other again? And I'm thinking to myself, again? This didn't happen.
我惊呆了，因为我不敢相信他竟然在给我打电话，我竟然真的在和他通话，和我曾经短暂迷恋过的那个男人说话。真的是他。他开始告诉我，他很高兴收到我的来信，因为，没错，他就是机场的那个人。多么巧合，他明天要去洛杉矶写稿，我们能再见一面吗？我在心里想，再见一面？这根本没发生过。
And I'm really worried that he thinks that I'm somebody else. Like, maybe he met some other girl in the airport a long time ago, and he thinks that I'm that girl. And when he meets me, he's going to be really disappointed that I'm not whoever he was thinking of.
我非常担心他以为我是别人。比如，也许他很久以前在机场遇到了别的女孩，他以为我是那个女孩。当他见到我时，他会因为我不是他心目中的那个人而非常失望。
Right.
对。
But I also don't want to correct him because then I think if I tell him, you know what? Actually, I made the whole thing up, and I just wanted to get to meet you, he'll think I'm insane, and he won't want to meet me. So I decide that I will meet him, but I will tell him the truth immediately upon meeting him.
但我也不想纠正他，因为我想如果我告诉他，你知道吗？其实，整件事都是我编的，我只是想见你，他会觉得我疯了，他也就不会想见我了。所以我决定去见他，但在见面时立刻告诉他真相。
Wait. You know, there's a third option. And that is that he knows he didn't meet you, but he just wants to meet a girl.
等等。你知道，还有第三种选择。那就是他知道他没见过你，但他只是想见个女孩。
You know, I thought about that. And there was actually a fourth option, which was he knows that I'm screwing with him, and he's just getting back at me by kind of playing the game.
你知道，我考虑过。其实还有第四种可能，那就是他知道我在耍他，他只是在配合我玩这个游戏，以此来报复我。
Wow. I have to say, like, you were meeting him-- like, for him to be the person on the phone when you're expecting the cable guy, did that make it seem more romantic? Like, you guys were meeting so cute. Or did it make it feel like you didn't even want to deal?
哇。我不得不说，你见他的时候——他竟然在你等安装工的时候打来电话，这让一切显得更浪漫了吗？你们的邂逅是不是很奇妙？还是说你觉得根本没心思应付？
Oh, no. The minute I found out that it was him, I completely regressed back into my state of obsession. And in terms of meeting cute, actually, he was coming to LA, and I was going to New York. And we were going to miss each other completely. It was like a romantic comedy, but it turned out that my flight back to LA was an hour before his outgoing flight back to New York. So it turned out we were going to be in the same terminal at the same time at LAX. So he said, wouldn't it be great to meet in the airport again?
哦，不。我一发现是他，就立刻退回了那种痴迷的状态。至于邂逅，其实他要来洛杉矶，而我要去纽约。我们要错开了。这就像浪漫喜剧一样，但结果我回洛杉矶的航班比他去纽约的航班早一个小时。所以结果是我们会在洛杉矶机场的同一个航站楼。他说，再在机场见一面岂不是很好？
Which, of course, was the single most confusing thing that he could possibly say. Because on the one hand, you know, how fated, how romantic comedy can you get? Both at the airport, right? And then on the other hand, what the hell is he talking about? They've never met.
当然，这是他能说的最让人困惑的一句话。因为一方面，你知道，多么宿命，多么像浪漫喜剧啊？都在机场，对吧？而另一方面，他到底在说什么？他们根本没见过面。
Well, today on our radio show, we have three stories of mind games, situations where a simple deception goes way out of hand and leads to all kinds of things that it was never intended to lead to. You're listening to This American Life , by the way, from Chicago Public Radio. I'm Ira Glass.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们有三个关于心理游戏的故事，简单欺骗如何演变得不可收拾，并导致了种种始料未及的后果。顺便说一下，你正在收听的是芝加哥公共广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Later in our program today, we have the story of self-appointed secret agents going around New York City hoping to serve the forces of good and not evil till things get more emotional than they planned. And a musician talks about a very unusual, slightly mind-bending request by one of his fans.
节目稍后，我们将讲述自封特工在纽约市为了正义而奔走，直到事情变得比他们预想中更感性。还有一位音乐家谈到了粉丝提出的一个非常不同寻常、甚至有点让人思维混乱的请求。
But before we get any of that, consider what happened to Lori. Her travel plans change. She can't meet the guy at the airport. And so instead, she shows up, and she has a drink with him at his hotel. And the first surprise is he looks nothing, nothing like his picture.
但在那之前，想想洛莉的遭遇。她的行程改变了。她无法在机场见到那个男人。于是，她出现在他的酒店和他喝了一杯。第一个意外是，他长得跟他照片上一模一样——完全不像。
And I didn't quite know what to do about that because he looked so unlike his picture that at that point, I wondered if he was actually the guy or if he had sent-- like, he was playing a mind game with me. And he had sent some other guy to kind of go on the date with me.
我完全不知道该怎么办，因为他长得和他照片一点都不像，当时我怀疑他到底是不是那个人，或者他是否派了别人——他在跟我玩心理游戏。他派了别人来跟我约会。
Wow. I love how because you're running a con, suddenly you believe everybody's running a con.
哇。我喜欢这种感觉，因为你在设局，所以你突然觉得每个人都在设局。
Well, your sense of reality gets turned upside down. It's like you think, I'm an honest person, and I did this. So who knows what other people are doing?
嗯，你的现实感会被颠覆。你心想，我是个诚实的人，连我都做了这种事。那么谁知道别人在做什么呢？
So she sits there. And the longer she sits there, the more that she could see that, yes, when he turns his head this particular way, he probably is the guy in the photo. Not that that helps anything. She is not liking the real him, not attracted.
所以她坐在那里。她坐得越久，就越能看出，是的，当他把头转到某个特定角度时，他很可能就是照片里的那个人。但这并没有什么帮助。她不喜欢真实的他，没有吸引力。
And because I'm not interested, I'm kind of deciding, do I need to even tell him that I made this up? Or can I just leave?
因为我不感兴趣，我正在考虑，我需要告诉他这一切是我编的吗？还是我可以直接走人？
Oh, right.
哦，对。
He doesn't need to know that I made up the story. But then, on the other hand, it was sort of strange because he kept talking about our encounter in the airport. And it was kind of frustrating to me because I felt like, why is he doing this? I couldn't understand why he would do this. It wasn't just that he had seen my letter and kind of went with it. It was like he then took the letter to a whole new level of deception.
他没必要知道我编了那个故事。但另一方面，这有点奇怪，因为他一直谈论我们在机场的邂逅。我感到很沮丧，因为我觉得，他为什么要这么做？我无法理解他为什么要这么做。不仅仅是因为他看到了我的信并顺着话头接下去。他好像把那封信带到了一个新的欺骗高度。
First he said, when I met him at the bar-- the first thing he said to me was, oh, I recognized you immediately. You look exactly the same as you did in the airport. Then, when we were talking, he'd come up-- he'd just, like, pepper the conversation with all these little lies, like he said that when we were in the airport, he remembered that I was confused about what I wanted to do with my life.
首先，当我在酒吧见到他时——他对我说的第一件事是，哦，我一眼就认出你了。你看上去和在机场时一模一样。后来我们聊天时，他会时不时在对话中掺杂各种小谎言，比如他说当我们在机场时，他记得我很困惑自己想在生活中做什么。
So he says to me-- you know, the bar closes. And he says, do you want to come up and continue talking? And I wanted to leave really badly at that point. But because I'd been there for so many hours, I thought, I cannot leave and not find out, not get to the bottom of this story. And I feel so guilty at this point that I really feel like I have to come clean.
于是他跟我说——酒吧要关门了。他说，你想上去继续聊聊吗？我当时非常想离开。但因为我在那儿坐了几个小时，我想，我不能就这么走掉，而不找出真相，不把这件事查个水落石出。那一刻我感到如此内疚，我觉得我必须坦白。
Right.
对。
So I go upstairs. And I say to him, you know, I have to tell you, I really don't think that you're the guy from the airport. It's been really nice meeting you, but you're not the guy. And he says, no, no, no. I am. And he's very insistent about it. And it's sort of like once he had his own position, he didn't want to change his position.
所以我上楼了。我对他说，你知道，我必须告诉你，我真的不认为你是机场那个人。很高兴见到你，但你不是那个人。他说，不，不，不。我是。他非常坚持。就好像一旦他确立了自己的立场，就不想改变了。
So I say to him, you know, actually, it really wasn't you because I made the whole thing up. And he is stunned into silence. And I think, oh, god. He thinks I'm a freak. And I'm sitting there thinking, I just want to crawl into a hole right now. I should never have told him the truth. And then he just looks at me very calmly and says, no, you didn't. I remember this.
所以我对他说，你知道，其实真的不是你，因为整件事都是我编的。他惊呆了，沉默不语。我想，天哪。他一定觉得我是个怪胎。我坐在那儿想，我现在只想找个地缝钻进去。我真不该告诉他真相。然后他平静地看着我说，不，你没有。我记得这件事。
And I look at him like, what is he doing? I can't imagine what he's doing. Why is he doing that? Is he trying to save face for me? And he wasn't, like, sort of excited about it. He was, like, cool as a cucumber. He was like, no. It happened. I remember. And it was like it made me seem crazy.
我看着他，心想他在干什么？我无法想象他在做什么。为什么要那样？他是在帮我挽回面子吗？他并没有表现得兴奋，他冷静得像个黄瓜。他说，不。那是真的。我记得。就好像这让我看起来疯了一样。
Yeah.
对。
You know, like, all of a sudden, you know how you appear crazier when you're trying to prove to somebody that you're not crazy?
你知道，突然间，你知道当你试图向别人证明你没疯时，你会显得更疯吗？
Yes.
是的。
And basically, I said, look, I got to go. And oddly, then he said at the door, he's like, can I kiss you? And I just gave him my cheek. And then he gave me his card. And I left.
总之，我说，听着，我得走了。奇怪的是，他在门口说，我可以吻你吗？我只是把脸颊凑了过去。然后他给了我一张名片。我就离开了。
But there are only two possibilities. Either he actually believes that he met you or he knows he didn't. Right?
但只有两种可能。要么他真的以为他见过你，要么他知道他没见过。对吧？
Right. But let's say that he believed that he met me. Reverse the situation. If somebody said to me, you know, I think I met you in the airport, and I believed them, and then they said, I made it all up, I would believe them. I would say, oh, huh. You know, I thought that actually you were telling the truth. But if you say you made it up, you must have made it up. Like, what would be my motive for telling him I made the whole thing up?
对。但假设他以为他见过我。倒过来想。如果有人对我说，你知道，我想我在机场见过你，我信了，然后他们说，这一切都是我编的，我会相信他们的。我会说，哦，呵。你知道，我以为你是说真的。但如果你说你是编的，那肯定就是编的。我想，我有什么动机告诉他这一切是我编的呢？
Yeah. I find that very convincing, actually. I wasn't actually sure what I thought up until you said that. But actually, now I actually believe that he completely knew that he was lying. I actually believe there's no chance that he actually thought he met you.
是的。这很有说服力。在你这么说之前，我其实不确定我自己怎么想。但现在，我真的相信他完全知道自己在撒谎。我不觉得有任何可能他真的以为他见过你。
There's no reason for him not to believe me except for the fact that I've already established myself as a liar because I'm telling him I lied and sent you this note that was a complete lie.
除了我已经把自己塑造成一个骗子这一事实外，没有理由让他不相信我，因为我告诉他我撒了谎，发了那封完全是胡编乱造的信给他。
I love how this started off as, like, this innocent little romantic lie. And then, before it's done, you yourself are caught up in this whole world of where you can't even figure out how to convince him, and you can't figure out why he's saying what he's saying. Like, your mind is so messed with by the end of this story.
我喜欢这个故事开始时像是一个天真浪漫的小谎言。最后，连你自己都被卷入了一个世界，你甚至无法弄清楚该如何说服他，也无法弄清楚他为什么要说那些话。你的脑子在这个故事结束时简直乱透了。
Yeah. I don't know what to make of it. I mean, years later, I don't know what to make of it. It's this thing that I sort of-- whatever went on in that room that night, it's like it stayed with me for so many years because it was so confusing to me.
是的。我不知道该怎么理解。我的意思是，多年后，我依然不知道该怎么理解。这件事——那天晚上房间里发生的一切，它困扰了我很多年，因为它让我太困惑了。
Lori Gottlieb. She's the author of "Marry Him-- The Case of Settling for Mr. Good Enough." She's now a psychotherapist in Los Angeles.
洛莉·戈特利布。她是《嫁给他——关于找个“足够好”的对象的论述》一书的作者。她现在是洛杉矶的一名心理治疗师。
Act Two, The Spy Who Loved Everyone. We have this story of good intentions and where they lead from Jorge Just.
第二幕，爱所有人的间谍。我们有乔治·贾斯特带来的关于好意及其导致结果的故事。
It's a Saturday in January, dead of winter, a crowded subway car, New York City.
那是冬日的一月，一个周六，纽约市挤满人的地铁车厢。
"Stand clear of the closing doors, please."
“请远离车门。”
At the Canal Street Station, a guy walks onto the car. He's wearing a hat, gloves, scarf, and coat, but no pants. At the next stop, Spring Street, someone else gets on with no pants. This continues for a half dozen stops.
在运河街站，一个男人走上车。他戴着帽子、手套、围巾和外套，但没穿裤子。下一站春街站，又上来一个人，没穿裤子。这种情况持续了半打车站。
The car's filling up with pantsless people who don't seem to know or even notice each other. Reactions vary. Some riders avert their eyes. Some laugh out loud. Some stare, turn away, stare again. Finally at 33rd Street, somebody new comes through the car. It's a vendor. She's selling pants.
车厢里挤满了没穿裤子的人，他们看起来并不认识对方，甚至没有注意到对方。反应各异。有的乘客避开目光。有的放声大笑。有的盯着看，转过头，又盯着看。终于到了33街，有一个人走过车厢。是个小贩。她在卖裤子。
"Short pants! Medium pants. Anyone need pants? $1."
“短裤！中号裤子。有人需要裤子吗？1美元。”
It won't shock you to know that this whole scene was staged. The pantsless people are part of a group called Improv Everywhere led by a New Yorker named Charlie Todd. He pulls stunts like this all over New York. He calls them missions. The people that carry them out are called agents. Here's how Charlie explains it.
你知道这一切是策划好的，肯定不会感到惊讶。这些不穿裤子的人是“到处即兴表演”（Improv Everywhere）组织的一部分，由纽约人查理·托德领导。他经常在纽约策划这类活动。他称之为“任务”。执行这些任务的人被称为“特工”。查理是这样解释的。
It's always hard for me to describe it because I always want to use the word prank. But prank always has that negative connotation of in order for there to be a prank, there has to be a victim, somebody who has been fooled and has been embarrassed or humiliated or had the best of. And what we try to do is really the opposite. We try to make people happy.
我一直很难描述它，因为我总是想用“恶作剧”这个词。但恶作剧总有负面含义，为了有恶作剧，就必须有一个受害者，一个被愚弄并感到尴尬、羞辱或被欺负的人。而我们努力做的是完全相反的事情。我们努力让人开心。
For Charlie, happy means fun, and fun means making strange things happen in boring locations. Take mission 27, the Mobius.
对于查理来说，开心意味着有趣，有趣意味着在无聊的地方制造奇怪的事情。以27号任务——莫比乌斯为例。
The Mobius mission was a time loop in a Starbucks.
莫比乌斯任务是星巴克里的时间循环。
It worked like this. Charlie and six friends choreographed a five-minute sequence of events to repeat over and over again. They planned it at a Starbucks, and they performed it at another, the one across the street. Each agent had their own action. Charlie and his girlfriend started off. They walk in and get in line. Charlie notices a pack of cigarettes in her purse and confronts her about her smoking.
它是这样运作的。查理和六个朋友精心策划了一个五分钟的时间循环。他们在一家星巴克策划，在街对面的一家表演。每个特工都有自己的动作。查理和女友开始，走进去排队。查理发现她包里有一包烟，并质问她抽烟的事。
She says, don't tell me what to do, and storms out of the Starbucks. And I run out after her yelling her name-- "Katie, come back." And then, four minutes later, we walk back into Starbucks, get in line again. And so that's our loop.
她说，别管我，然后冲出了星巴克。我追着她跑出去，喊她的名字——“凯蒂，回来。”四分钟后，我们走回星巴克，重新排队。这就是我们的循环。
Agent number three spills his water, stands up, gets napkins, comes back to clean up the mess, and repeats. That's his loop. Agent number four answers a phone call, walks to the window for better reception, then goes back to his chair. Agent number five gets up to go to the bathroom, decides the line is too long, returns to his seat. Agent number six simply sneezes at a precise moment.
特工三号洒了水，站起来，拿餐巾纸，回来清理烂摊子，然后重复。那是他的循环。特工四号接了个电话，走到窗边为了信号更好，然后回到座位。特工五号起身要去厕所，发现排队太长，回到座位。特工六号只是在精确的时间打了个喷嚏。
And the capper was my friend Ken would walk through the Starbucks with a boom box playing "Shiny, Happy People" by REM. And he would walk in one door, go through the entire restaurant, walk out the other door. We repeated that sequence 12 times in a row, for an hour total.
压轴戏是我朋友肯拿着立体声录音机走过星巴克，放着REM的《闪亮，快乐的人们》。他从一个门进去，穿过整个餐厅，从另一个门走出来。我们连续重复了12次那个序列，总共一小时。
Charlie says that for the first few repetitions, nobody noticed a thing. It was the argument between Charlie and his girlfriend that finally caught people's attention.
查理说，最初几次循环，没人注意到任何事。最终引起人们注意的，是查理和他女朋友的争吵。
By, like, the third or fourth time that I had run out the Starbucks chasing after my girlfriend, people were starting to say, like, well, if I was him, I'd just break up with her. But it wasn't that they thought that they were in a time loop. It was that they thought that we really just kept getting into a fight.
大概第三或第四次我冲出星巴克去追女友时，人们开始说，嗯，如果我是他，我早就跟她分手了。但他们并不是认为自己处在时间循环中。他们认为我们真的一直在吵架。
And then by, like, the fifth and sixth time that we did it, people kind of started to get freaked out. There was one woman in particular who we had on the hidden camera who called her friend and said, "you have to come down here. I'm at the Starbucks in Astor Place. I don't know what's going on."
大概第五或第六次时，人们开始感到害怕。有一个女人被我们的隐蔽摄像头拍到，她给朋友打电话说，“你必须到这来。我在阿斯特广场的星巴克。我不知道发生了什么。”
I don't know if you've ever been in a Starbucks, but if you do go, you'll notice lots of people doing the same sort of thing over and over again-- sip the coffee, read the paper, update the blog. Stare hard enough, and everyone looks like they're in a time loop. It took people almost an hour to find the line between staged scene and reality.
我不知道你有没有去过星巴克，但如果你去，你会发现很多人在做同样的重复动作——抿咖啡、读报纸、更新博客。盯得够久，每个人看起来都像是处在时间循环里。人们花了将近一小时才找出策划场景与现实之间的界线。
By the end of it-- by, like, the 9th and 10th time we're doing it-- the whole Starbucks is talking to each other, participating in this thing. It's almost as if everybody in that Starbucks felt like they could predict the future. And they started kind of, like, conducting it. Like, they would point at Chris and say, "oh, and he's going to sneeze right now. And here comes the boom box guy again. And oh, that means the couple's coming back. And there they are!" And then, after the 12th time, we just left.
到最后——大概第九或第十次的时候——整个星巴克的人都在交流，参与其中。仿佛星巴克里的每个人都觉得他们能预测未来。他们开始指挥这一切。比如，他们指着克里斯说，“哦，他马上就要打喷嚏了。录音机男又来了。哦，那意味着那对情侣又要回来了。看，他们在那儿！”第12次之后，我们就离开了。
In a way, this might be the most surprising part of the Mobius mission. After going to that much trouble just to provide a roomful of strangers with an unforgettable memory, the members of Improv Everywhere get up and they leave, and not just because you can't close a curtain on a coffee shop time loop. Charlie posts pictures and descriptions of the missions on his website, but that's as close as he gets to a standing ovation. He's got loftier goals, anyway.
在某种程度上，这可能是莫比乌斯任务最令人惊讶的部分。在付出那么多努力只是为了给满屋子的陌生人提供一段难忘的回忆后，“到处即兴表演”的成员们起身就走，不仅仅是因为你不能在咖啡店的时间循环上拉下帷幕。查理把照片和任务描述发在他的网站上，但这已是他能得到的最近似的掌声了。反正他有更崇高的目标。
I want to live in a world where anything can happen. I guess what I mean by that is-- I don't know. I guess we shouldn't have to rely on, like, television or movies to show us fantastic things and fantastic stories. Let's attempt to bring some of that excitement to the real world, I guess.
我想生活在一个任何事情都可能发生的世界里。我想我的意思是——不知道。我觉得我们不应该只依赖电视或电影来向我们展示梦幻般的事物和故事。让我们尝试将那种兴奋带入现实世界，我想。
Charlie's missions are cool, but it's his objective that's intriguing-- to create fun, inexplicable experiences for random strangers. It's like giving people a small, unexpected gift and, in the process, making the world seem a bit more enchanted. But as anyone who's read a children's book can attest, mess with the forces of enchantment and things can go terribly, terribly wrong. And that's what happened with a mission Charlie calls the Best Gig Ever.
查理的任务很酷，但最吸引人的是他的目标——为随机的陌生人创造有趣、无法解释的经历。这就像给人们一份小而意外的礼物，在此过程中，让世界看起来更迷人一些。但正如任何读过童话书的人所能证明的那样，干扰魔法力量会让事情变得糟糕透顶。而这正是查理称之为“有史以来最棒演出”的任务中所发生的事情。
The Best Gig Ever, an idea. My friend Mark Lee came up to me one night. And he came up to me and said, let's find a rock band, a struggling rock band, and give them the greatest gig of their life. So I researched on the internet for the next couple of weeks trying to find the perfect gig, the perfect band who I knew was setting themselves up for just a horrible audience.
“有史以来最棒演出”，一个想法。我的朋友马克·李一天晚上来找我。他提议说，让我们找一支摇滚乐队，一支挣扎中的摇滚乐队，给他们一场一生中最棒的演出。于是我在接下来的几周里在互联网上做了研究，试图找到完美的演出，完美的乐队，我知道他们正准备面对一场糟糕的观众。
And I found this band, Ghosts of Pasha, from Vermont. Never heard of them before. Nobody in New York had probably heard of them apart from their friends because it was their first tour ever. And they had just recorded some songs this summer, and they were gonna tour in October. And they were playing a gig in New York on Friday night at 8 o'clock for a $5 cover. Then they had a gig two nights later on Sunday night at the Mercury Lounge for an $8 cover at 10 PM.
我找到了这支乐队，来自佛蒙特的“帕夏的幽灵”（Ghosts of Pasha）。从没听说过他们。纽约可能没人听说过他们，除了他们的朋友，因为这是他们第一次巡演。他们夏天刚录了一些歌，要在十月巡演。周五晚上8点，他们在纽约有一场演出，票价5美元。两天后的周日晚上10点，他们在水银酒廊（Mercury Lounge）还有一场演出，票价8美元。
So I knew, even if they had friends in New York, those friends would come to the Friday night show, and they would not come back. No matter how good the show was, they're not coming out at 10 o'clock on a Sunday night to support their friends again.
我知道，即使他们在纽约有朋友，那些朋友也会来周五晚上的演出，但他们不会再来了。无论演出有多棒，他们不会在周日晚上10点出来再次支持他们的朋友。
Charlie recruited 35 agents to act as hardcore Ghosts of Pasha fans. They downloaded the six songs on the band's website, and they memorized the lyrics. Some agents made T-shirts and temporary tattoos using the Ghosts of Pasha logo. They timed their arrival, getting to the club as the next-to-last band was getting off the stage.
查理招募了35名特工担任“帕夏的幽灵”的铁粉。他们下载了乐队网站上的六首歌，背下了歌词。一些特工用“帕夏的幽灵”标志制作了T恤和纹身贴纸。他们算准了抵达时间，在上一支乐队下台时进入俱乐部。
People entered separately or in pairs, didn't act like we knew each other. And by the time they were doing their sound check, all of us were in the room. Not only were they getting ready to perform, we were getting ready to perform, too. And everybody from the previous gig had left. They had three paying customers that night not counting us. But instead, they had 38-- the 35 of us and the three paying customers. And once they got on stage and said, hello, Mercury Lounge or whatever they said, we definitely exploded.
人们分别或成对进入，表现得好像互不相识。在他们试音时，我们所有人都在房里了。不仅他们准备演出，我们也准备表演。上一场演出的所有人都离开了。那晚除了我们，只有三个付钱的顾客。但他们实际上有38个观众——我们35个加上那三个付钱的。一旦他们上台说，你好，水银酒廊或随便什么，我们绝对炸开了。
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
We're Ghosts of Pasha.
我们是帕夏的幽灵。
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
You're listening to footage from a video camera that one of Charlie's friends snuck into the Mercury. The club was dark, and the camera was hidden in a bag. At first, you can't make anything out, but then the camera goes into night-vision mode, and it's all there in black and pale green and white. 35 people isn't much of a crowd, but somehow, they make it seem like the place is packed.
你听到的是查理的朋友偷偷带进水银酒廊的摄像机录下的素材。俱乐部很黑，摄像机藏在包里。起初，你什么也看不清，但后来摄像机进入夜视模式，一切都在黑色、淡绿色和白色中呈现。35个人算不上拥挤，但不知何故，他们让那个地方看起来人满为患。
I sat and watched the video with Charlie, who pointed out his favorite moments and showed me how the agents reacted to the music in their own particular ways, some pushing to the front, others hanging back. He points out another guy near the front of the stage. He's dancing spastically, flinging his arms, shaking to the music.
我坐着和查理一起看录像，他指出他最喜欢的瞬间，向我展示了特工们如何以各自独特的方式对音乐做出反应，有的挤到前面，有的向后退。他指着舞台附近另一个人。他正在疯狂跳舞，挥舞手臂，跟着音乐颤抖。
At a show, there is always that one guy who's dancing too much. And the guy we're looking at now, he's that guy. You know? So it's appropriate. We're not all doing it, but he is.
演出时，总有那么一个跳舞跳得太疯的人。我们现在看到的这个人，就是那个人。你知道吗？所以这很合适。我们没全这样做，但他做了。
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
Charlie spends most of the show taking pictures. Each rock crowd has one of those kids, too. But at a certain moment, even he gets swept up in the excitement and starts acting more like he does when he's seeing his favorite band, The Cure.
查理大部分时间都在拍照。每个摇滚乐迷群里也都有那种孩子。但在某一刻，连他也被兴奋所感染，开始表现得像他在看他最喜欢的乐队“治疗乐队”（The Cure）时那样。
And then I will say that at this moment right here, I am definitely, like, into the show.
我会说，就在这一刻，我绝对沉浸在演出了。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
We were requesting songs. You know, we only knew the names of, like, six songs because they only had six songs on their EP, which they had on their website. And I was screaming for-- they have a song called "What About the Shut-Ins." It's like [SINGING] what about the shut-ins of the Second World War? And I was screaming for "Shut-Ins." I just yelling, "Shut-Ins!" "Shut-Ins!"
我们在点歌。你知道，我们只知道六首歌的名字，因为他们EP里只有六首歌，他们网站上有。我一直在大喊——他们有一首歌叫《那些禁足的孩子》（What About the Shut-Ins）。就像[唱歌]二战中的那些禁足者怎么了？我一直在喊“禁足者！”“禁足者！”
And they played it. I think probably coincidentally, they were playing it next in the set. And I just went crazy when they started. When I heard the first notes, I was like, yeah! I got my request.
他们唱了。我想可能纯属巧合，他们接下来的曲目里正好有这首。当他们开始时，我简直疯了。听到第一个音符时，我心想，耶！我点歌成功了。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
Where is the difference in really, really being into a band and pretending to be really into a band?
真正沉浸在乐队中和假装沉浸在乐队中有什么区别吗？
Yeah, there's not much difference for that night. It felt just like I was at a Cure show singing along to "Just Like Heaven." You know, I was at Ghost of Pasha singing along to "What About the Shut-Ins." Whatever. It was the same thing, basically.
是的，那一晚没多大区别。感觉就像我在看“治疗乐队”演唱会跟着唱《就像天堂》（Just Like Heaven）。你知道，我在看“帕夏的幽灵”演唱会跟着唱《那些禁足的孩子》。管它呢。基本上是一回事。
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
[CROWD CHANTING "PASHA"]
[人群高呼“帕夏”]
Thanks a lot. Audience, audience, audience, audience!
多谢。观众，观众，观众，观众！
The band gets offstage, and Charlie and company leave the bar to go celebrate another mission accomplished. A couple of days later, he puts up pictures and reports of the evening on his website. Charlie figured the band would find his page in a month or two. It's basically inevitable once he's posted everything online. What he wasn't sure of is how they would react.
乐队下台，查理和伙伴们离开酒吧庆祝又一项任务完成。几天后，他把那天晚上的照片和报告发到了网站上。查理原以为乐队会在一两个月内发现他的网页。一旦他把一切发到网上，这基本是不可避免的。他不确定的是他们会作何反应。
When I would tell people this idea, like, as I was preparing for this event, one of the main responses I got was people saying, like, that is so cruel. You know, what's going to happen when this band does their next gig in New York City and nobody shows up? That is the cruelest thing I've ever heard.
当我在准备这个活动时，告诉人们这个想法，我得到的主要反应之一是人们说，那太残忍了。你知道，当这支乐队在纽约市进行下一次演出而没人来的时候会发生什么？那是我听过的最残忍的事。
And I just-- I really don't buy into that logic. I think-- I mean, it's kind of an interesting thing to think about. Like, is it cruel to give somebody the best day of their life just because they'll never have another day like that again?
但我真的不买账。我认为——我的意思是，这是一个有趣的思考。给某人一天中最棒的一天，只因为他们再也不会有那样的日子了，这残忍吗？
And I don't think so. I mean, it's kind of like you have a wonderful dream, and you wake up. And do you wish you just had bad dreams every night? And I think it's great to have wonderful dreams. And yeah, it kind of sucks for a second. But you always have that moment.
我不这么认为。这就像你做了一个美梦，然后醒了。你希望自己每晚都做噩梦吗？我认为拥有美梦很棒。是的，那一瞬间感觉有点糟。但你永远拥有那一刻。
[CROWD CHANTING "PASHA"]
[人群高呼“帕夏”]
We got punked. That show at the Mercury Lounge was a fake. And it just seemed like a blow. Like, it was like a blow to my heart.
我们被耍了。在水银酒廊的那场演出是假的。这就像一个重击。就像对我的心沉重一击。
This is Chris Partyka, the guitarist of Ghosts of Pasha. It turns out that finding Charlie's website was a bit worse than waking from a dream, and it happened faster than Charlie expected. Lead singer Milo Finch found out only three days after the show. His discovery was a disturbing capper to an already long and bizarre few days.
这是“帕夏的幽灵”的吉他手克里斯·帕蒂卡。事实证明，发现查理的网站比从梦中醒来还要糟，而且发生得比查理预想的更快。主唱米洛·芬奇在演出后仅三天就发现了。他的发现是这原本漫长而怪异的几天中令人不安的压轴戏。
To understand how weird this was for the band, you need to hear the story from their perspective. They hadn't even wanted to play the Mercury show in the first place. They were exhausted.
要理解这对乐队来说有多怪异，你需要从他们的角度听这个故事。他们根本不想进行水银酒廊的演出。他们精疲力竭。
They'd just driven from Vermont to Boston for a show Thursday, and to New York for a show on Friday. Ezra, the drummer, and Brad, the bassist, had then driven the six hours back to Vermont on Saturday, and then turned around and returned Sunday. Milo stayed in New York, but he'd been up all night partying.
他们刚刚从佛蒙特开车到波士顿参加周四的演出，周五又开车到纽约参加演出。鼓手埃兹拉和贝斯手布拉德在周六又开了六小时车回到佛蒙特，周日又折返回来。米洛留在纽约，但他彻夜狂欢没睡。
I remember being on the street before the Mercury Lounge show completely exhausted, just sitting on the street waiting to play. We didn't even want to do it. But you know, I remember just sitting there. And it was pretty dead. And we thought it was just gonna be dead. And we were like, cool. It'll be dead. We can just go up there and play and just get out of here.
我记得在水银酒廊演出前我在街上，精疲力尽，只是坐在街上等演出。我们甚至不想做这件事。但我记得我只是坐在那儿。那里很冷清。我们以为肯定没人。我们心想，酷。会没人来的。我们可以上台演完就走。
Get it over with.
结束它。
It turns out that the band Charlie picked wasn't just obscure. It was practically brand new. They'd only been together a couple of months. This was their fourth show ever, the third on their tour.
事实证明，查理挑选的乐队不仅默默无闻，而且几乎是全新的。他们在一起才几个月。这是他们第四场演出，巡演的第三场。
It was really weird because we knew this was our third show. I remember turning to the drummer, to Ezra, and being like, what's going on? Like, in the middle of a song, like a drum break.
这真的很怪，因为我们知道这是我们的第三场演出。我记得转头对鼓手埃兹拉说，怎么回事？在歌中间，比如鼓点间歇时。
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
What started weird soon got weirder. Keep in mind, they hadn't put out an album. Nobody anywhere had ever heard of them. But somehow, a crowd of New Yorkers knew their lyrics.
奇怪的事情很快变得更奇怪了。记住，他们还没出过专辑。任何地方没人听过他们。但不知何故，一群纽约人知道他们的歌词。
The first song we noticed it was in "New York, New York." It's one of our songs, and right off the bat is the chorus. And they came right in with it. Like, I think they came in with it on better timing than I did. They came right in. And they nailed it.
第一首我们注意到的是《纽约，纽约》。这是我们的歌，合唱一出，他们立刻就接上了。我想他们接得比我还准。他们直接跟上了。他们做到了。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
Honestly, it was really odd. I mean, there was moments where guys were ripping off their shirts and swinging them over their heads in, like, a helicopter fashion. There were girls that were pointing at the stage and interacting with me as we were pointing back. It was just-- it was bedlam.
老实说，真的很怪。我的意思是，有那么一瞬间，男人们脱掉衬衫，像直升机一样在头顶挥舞。有女孩指着舞台，我们指回去时她们和我有互动。那真是——简直是混乱。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
The exclamation point on the whole evening for me was how creepy it was when the guy jumped up on stage with no shirt. And I just remember him being up front the whole time punching the air and spinning in circles, and he was all sweaty. And he jumped up on stage at the end of the last song and hugged me. He's all sweaty and clammy. And he's like, thank you. Like, he just kept saying thank you in my ear. And I was just like, all right. Thank you.
那天晚上最让我震惊的是，当那个没穿衬衫的人跳上台时，那有多可怕。我只记得他一直在我面前挥拳，跟着音乐旋转，他全身是汗。在最后一首歌结束时，他跳上台拥抱了我。他全身又湿又黏。他一直在我耳边说谢谢。我只能说，好吧。谢谢。
Agent V.
特工V。
Yeah, Agent V. He seemed like he wasn't really acting, just getting it out, you know?
是的，特工V。他看起来不像是演的，只是在发泄，你知道吗？
The band got into it, too. Milo's favorite moment came at the end of the set.
乐队也沉浸其中。米洛最喜欢的时刻是在曲目结束时。
During the solo in "Power Bitch," I had kind of just laid on the stage. And the crowd rushed the stage and was grabbing my hands like this because I was right on the lip of the stage. And I put the microphone out into the audience, and they were screaming and grabbing at my hand and touching the microphone. And I made sure I slapped every hand that came up, just so no one felt like they didn't get it.
在《权力贱人》（Power Bitch）的独奏期间，我有点躺在舞台上。人群冲向舞台，抓着我的手，因为我就在舞台边上。我把麦克风伸向观众，他们尖叫着抓我的手，触摸麦克风。我确保我拍了每一只伸过来的手，这样没人觉得他们没参与到。
And however the act was going on or whatever they were pulling or whatever they were doing, I felt that at that point in the show, we answered it back with something real. And at that point, everybody in the room was on the same page.
不管那个表演是怎么回事，或者他们做了什么，我觉得在演出那一刻，我们用真实的东西回应了它。那一刻，房间里的每个人都在同一频率。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
[CROWD CHANTING "ONE MORE SONG"]
[人群高呼“再来一首”]
The show was exhausting. They played the tour's first ever encore and left all the energy they had on stage. Like Milo said, when a crowd screams at you like you're The Beatles, you act like you're The Beatles. Only this crowd stopped screaming the moment the last notes were played. Chris remembers unplugging his amp, looking up, and being shocked that the place was empty. Ghosts of Pasha were suddenly alone.
演出令人精疲力尽。他们进行了巡演中第一次返场表演，将所有能量留在了舞台上。就像米洛说的，当一群人像看披头士乐队一样对你尖叫时，你就会像披头士一样表演。只有这群人在最后一个音符结束时就停止了尖叫。克里斯记得拔掉扩音器电源，抬头看，震惊地发现地方空了。“帕夏的幽灵”突然孤身一人。
I remember we were all standing out on the street smoking our cigarette after the show, and totally confused.
我记得演出后我们都站在街上抽烟，完全困惑。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Kind of speechless for a little bit. I think I remember Brad broke the silence. He's always good for breaking the silence. He was like, what the [BLEEP] just happened? What the hell was that, I think was the-- what the hell was that? As he was lighting his cigarette. It was just creepy.
沉默了一会儿。我想我记得布拉德打破了沉默。他总是很擅长打破沉默。他说，刚才这他妈的是什么？我想大概是——那是什么鬼？当时他正在点烟。这太可怕了。
Creepy, but also pretty sweet.
可怕，但也挺甜美的。
You know, we just had nothing in our heads, so we just decided to fill it with, well, OK. We're really excited, and we're in a really good mood. So this is great. Finally, 35 people from New York City randomly came to our show and knew our words and stuff. And that's a good feeling.
你知道，我们当时脑子里一片空白，所以我们决定填补它，嗯，好的。我们真的很兴奋，心情很好。所以这很棒。终于有35个纽约人随机来到我们的演出，而且知道我们的词之类。那感觉真好。
You know what it was? I think some of the talking was we were addicted to it. We were like, that felt really cool. Let's play like that all the time. Let's get shows like that all the time.
你知道那是什么吗？我想有些讨论是因为我们对此上瘾了。我们心想，感觉真酷。让我们一直这样表演吧。让我们一直得到那样的演出吧。
That warm feeling lasted exactly three days, until somebody emailed them a link to Charlie's site. The band met up at the local computer lab and read it together. The next 48 hours were the worst. Email poured in mocking Ghosts of Pasha. Their website's bulletin board was flooded with people making fun of them. It got so bad they had to shut it down.
那种温暖的感觉持续了整整三天，直到有人给他们发了查理网站的链接。乐队在当地电脑室碰面一起读了它。接下来的48小时是最糟的。嘲笑“帕夏的幽灵”的电子邮件如潮水般涌入。他们网站的公告板上充斥着取笑他们的人。情况太糟了，他们不得不关掉它。
The band felt like the butt of a big joke. They struggled to take it all in stride, but inevitably, one member would get mad, and the others would have to talk him down. A couple of hours later, they'd be on the phone with each other again, making each other angry, calming each other down.
乐队感觉像个大笑话。他们努力坦然面对，但难免有一个成员会发火，其他成员得劝解他。几个小时后，他们又会打电话，让彼此生气，让彼此冷静。
The guitarist, Chris Partyka, was most affected. He got teased a lot as a kid, which is why he started playing music in the first place. It was something he could do by himself in his room, where nobody could make fun of him. News of the prank hit Chris pretty hard.
吉他手克里斯·帕蒂卡受影响最大。他小时候经常被取笑，这就是他一开始玩音乐的原因。这是他可以一个人在房间里做的事，没人能取笑他。恶作剧的新闻对克里斯打击很大。
It's the worst thing I could possibly think of ever happening to me in my life because I'd been avoiding confrontation my whole life so I wouldn't get made fun of. And the moment I decide that I want to try and be real and do what I really want to do, all of a sudden, it's reacted in the same way as it was when I was in kindergarten. And it's just like, what is the difference? You know? I'm 30 years old now, and I'm still getting made fun of by people.
这是我生命中能想到的最糟的事，因为我一生都在避免冲突，这样我就不会被取笑。而当我决定尝试真实地做我真正想做的事情的那一刻，突然间，反应和我在幼儿园时一模一样。就像，区别在哪？你知道吗？我现在30岁了，还在被人们取笑。
Knowing all this, it's surprising how Chris feels about it now, six months after it happened.
了解了这一切，很令人惊讶的是克里斯现在的感受，在事情过去六个月后。
It was a gift. It was the gift of, like, yeah, everything's OK. At this point, I don't really feel like anything can hurt me because I've dealt with what I've never thought that I could deal with before. It was like psychotherapy for my childhood. You know what I mean?
那是一份礼物。那是“是的，一切都好”的礼物。此时，我不觉得有什么能伤害我，因为我已经处理了我以前从未想过能处理的事情。那就像我童年的心理治疗。你知道我的意思吗？
Like, everybody in the world look at Chris. And everyone was like, duh! Look at him! Duh! You know? And then what am I supposed to do with that but be like, hey, how you doing? I'm Chris. I play the guitar, and I like it.
比如，全世界每个人都在看着克里斯。每个人都说，额！看他！额！你知道吗？然后我该怎么办，只能说，嘿，你好吗？我是克里斯。我弹吉他，我喜欢它。
After mulling it over for a few days, the band decided what to do. They wrote into Charlie's website with their own enthusiastic reports of the evening. Brad, the bassist, was terse. Chris, the guitarist, was thoughtful. And Milo, the lead singer, was the lead singer. Here's Charlie.
思索几天后，乐队决定怎么办。他们给查理的网站写了信，报告了那天晚上的热烈心情。贝斯手布拉德简短扼要。吉他手克里斯很有深思。主唱米洛还是那个主唱。这是查理。
The lead singer was really enthusiastic and upbeat about the whole thing. But you could tell that he definitely had, if not an ego, definitely had a lot of pride in the band and made that clear, too. And he had one line in his report that said, like, no matter what happened, we rocked the house that night, and you knew it. So there were elements of, like, we realize that it was a prank. But just so you know, we did rock it. And I agree with him. They did. They rocked it.
主唱对整件事非常热情和乐观。但你可以看出他肯定有，如果不说是自负，肯定对乐队有很高的自豪感，这一点也表露无疑。他在报告里有一行写着，不管发生了什么，那天晚上我们震撼了全场，你知道的。所以有一些元素，比如，我们意识到那是个恶作剧。但想让你知道，我们确实震撼了全场。我同意他。他们确实做到了。他们震撼了全场。
They rocked the show and snatched the opportunity. Bands need publicity, and Ghosts of Pasha knew a happy story sells better than a sad one. And they were right. The band was interviewed in Spin magazine. An A&R guy gave them a call. In other words, Ghosts of Pasha played along. They took Charlie's story about what happened that night and made it their own.
他们震撼了演出并抓住了机会。乐队需要宣传，“帕夏的幽灵”知道一个快乐的故事比一个悲伤的故事卖得更好。他们是对的。《Spin》杂志采访了他们。一位A&R人员给他们打了电话。换句话说，“帕夏的幽灵”配合了。他们接受了查理关于那天晚上发生的事情的故事，并将其变成了自己的。
But not everybody's ready to make themselves at home in Charlie's world. Some people prefer their life just the way it is.
但并非每个人都准备好在查理的世界里安家。有些人更喜欢现状。
All right. My name's Christopher Rawson. I am a fine art student going to New York University. And they basically threw me a fake birthday party.
好的。我叫克里斯托弗·罗森。我是纽约大学的美术专业学生。他们基本上给我办了一个假的生日派对。
The idea was to throw a birthday party for a stranger-- go up to someone in a bar, at random, and act like it was his birthday.
主意是为一个陌生人办生日派对——随机走到酒吧里的某人面前，装作是他的生日。
Charlie gathered about 30 Improv Everywhere agents and headed to a bar called Dempsy's to pick the evening star. He decided on Chris, who was sitting with a friend and a full pitcher of beer. It looked like they were settling in for the night. Charlie called the other agents and described Chris, and then he walked over and started the party.
查理召集了大约30名“到处即兴表演”特工，前往一家叫邓普西（Dempsy's）的酒吧挑选晚上的明星。他选中了克里斯，他正和朋友坐着，面前有一大扎啤酒。看起来他们打算在那儿待一晚。查理叫其他特工描述了克里斯，然后走过去开始了派对。
And I said, hey, Ted. How's it going? Sorry we're a little early for your birthday party. But thank you for inviting us.
我说，嘿，泰德。最近怎么样？抱歉我们提前了一点来参加你的生日派对。但谢谢你邀请我们。
They came up to me, and they just really addressed me as this other person, as Ted, and were just like, hey, what's up, buddy? Happy birthday.
他们走过来，直接把我当成了另一个人，当成了泰德，只是说，嘿，伙计，怎么了？生日快乐。
You know, he looks at me. And at first, he thinks it's just a case of misunderstanding. He's like, I'm sorry. You got the wrong guy. I'm not Ted. And I just laughed and said, ah, that's really funny, Ted. You did invite us to your birthday party. We got the Evite.
你知道，他看着我。起初，他以为只是误会。他说，抱歉。你找错人了。我不是泰德。我只是笑笑说，啊，真好笑，泰德。你确实邀请我们参加你的生日派对了。我们收到了邀请函。
A few minutes later, more people started coming in, and everybody was wishing me happy birthday and calling me by Ted. And everybody seemed to have this memory or this experience that they had with me in the past, which, obviously, was completely foreign to me.
几分钟后，更多人开始进来，每个人都在祝我生日快乐，叫我泰德。每个人似乎都有某种记忆或经历，以前和我有过，这显然对我来说完全陌生。
I had sent out an email to everybody involved with some specifics about this guy, Ted Hine, and said that he was 25 years old, that he went to UNC Chapel Hill, that he worked at Oppenheimer Funds, that his favorite band was Dave Matthews. Like, we came up with all these specifics about him. And I told everybody, pick out what your relationship is to Ted. Figure out what your story is, and stick to it.
我给所有参与者发了一封电子邮件，写了一些关于这个家伙泰德·海恩的细节，说他25岁，毕业于北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校，在奥本海默基金工作，最喜欢的乐队是戴夫·马修斯（Dave Matthews）。我们想出了所有关于他的细节。我告诉所有人，选好你和泰德的关系。弄清楚你的故事，并坚持住。
People were giving me hugs and being like, "oh, I haven't seen you in so long. What have you been up to?" And they had all kind of brought in little gift cards. And on all of them, they said, remember spring break, things relating to school. A few of the people thought I worked for some sort of bank or something.
人们给我拥抱，说，“哦，好久不见。你最近怎么样？”他们都带了小礼品卡。上面都写着，记得春假吗，关于学校的事情。几个人以为我是在银行之类的公司工作。
And he got really freaked out, which I didn't necessarily anticipate. But looking back on it, I guess I probably should have anticipated that that would freak somebody out.
他真的被吓坏了，这是我没预料到的。但回想起来，我想我应该预料到这会把人吓坏。
I was definitely freaked out and suspicious. I mean, it seemed very confrontational and very grotesque, even, I would say. So yeah, it was kind of like a really bad dream.
我绝对被吓坏了，并且感到怀疑。我的意思是，这看起来非常具有攻击性，甚至是非常怪诞。所以是的，这就像一场非常糟糕的噩梦。
Chris, it turns out, wasn't the brash 25-year-old East Villager that Charlie thought he'd chosen. He was actually a college student, a very young one, who'd recently transferred to NYU. If Charlie's the kind of guy who goes out in the world and makes things happen, then Chris is the kind who stays closer to home. He's thoughtful and sensitive and shy. Chris likes to have things in a certain understandable order, and Charlie wasn't part of it.
克里斯原来并不是查理以为他选中的那个傲慢的25岁东村居民。他实际上是个大学生，非常年轻，最近转学到纽约大学。如果查理是那种会到世界上去创造事情发生的人，那么克里斯就是那种更接近家的人。他深思熟虑、敏感且害羞。克里斯喜欢事情有一定的逻辑顺序，而查理不属于其中。
There was no sense that it was kind of a charade. I mean, it all felt very natural. It felt really close to reality. But yet, it was so strange and different that it couldn't be. So there was definitely the worry, too, on my part, I guess, that I was going insane maybe. Because it made no sense, so I kind of felt like I was losing my mind, in that sense, like, the ability to rationalize what was happening because I really couldn't.
没有任何感觉这是一种闹剧。我的意思是，这一切感觉非常自然。感觉非常接近现实。但同时，它又是如此陌生和不同，以至于不可能存在。所以我的心里肯定也有那种担忧，我可能疯了。因为它毫无逻辑，所以我感觉自己正在失去理智，那种无法合理化正在发生的事情的能力，因为我真的无法做到。
He showed them his driver's license, but they laughed it off. And Chris couldn't shake the feeling that a guy named Ted, the real Ted, could show up at any moment to find Chris drinking Ted's free drinks and, even worse, blowing out Ted's candles and eating Ted's cake. But every time he tried to leave, a fake friend would stop him, beg him to stay, buy him a drink. And eventually, he just became Ted.
他给他们看了驾照，但他们一笑置之。克里斯无法摆脱一种感觉，即一个叫泰德的人，真正的泰德，可能会在任何时候出现，发现克里斯在喝泰德的免费酒，甚至更糟，吹灭泰德的蜡烛，吃泰德的蛋糕。但每次他试图离开，一个假朋友就会阻止他，求他留下，给他买酒。最终，他成了泰德。
It was pretty much my only option. And I think that was the moment of the shift, was kind of realizing that. I was like, OK. Well, if they all think I'm Ted, then what the hell.
这几乎是我唯一的选择。我想那就是转变的时刻，意识到这一点。我心想，好吧。既然他们都以为我是泰德，那就随它去吧。
He starts answering to Ted. He starts introducing himself as Ted to kind of the latecomers. And in the end, he was not only just agreeing that he was Ted. He was corroborating all of our stories.
他开始以泰德的身份回应。他开始向后来者介绍自己为泰德。最后，他不仅同意自己是泰德，还印证了我们所有的故事。
People are like, oh, remember this? And I was like, oh, yeah. That was great. What a great time. And just kind of played along with it. And I think I just kind of decided that maybe I could, by assuming that identity, have some control or some say in the situation.
人们说，哦，记得那个吗？我回答说，哦，是的。太棒了。多么好的时光。就这样顺着演下去了。我想我只是决定，也许通过承担那个身份，我可以对局势有一定的控制或发言权。
It was disappointing at first, to see this guy get freaked out. And I was like, oh, no. My whole idea is to make this guy's night. To watch that transformation to the guy playing pool, doing shots, and getting phone numbers was really a blast to watch. And I can't decide in the end whether I picked the perfect guy or whether I picked the worst guy.
起初看到这家伙被吓坏很失望。我心想，哦，不。我的整个想法是让人家那一晚过得开心。看到他转变成那个打台球、喝烈酒、要电话号码的家伙，真是太棒了。我最终无法决定是我选了完美的人，还是选了最糟的人。
There may have been a worse Ted somewhere in the world, but probably not in that bar. Sure, he'd had fun. He even let them convince him to take the gift cards home. Chris rose to the challenge and became Ted. But by the next morning, he was Chris again, only he was Chris with another man's gift cards.
世界上某个地方可能有一个更糟的泰德，但肯定不在那个酒吧。当然，他玩得很开心。他甚至让他们说服他把礼品卡带回家。克里斯迎接了挑战，成了泰德。但第二天早上，他又成了克里斯，只是这个克里斯带着别人的礼品卡。
I don't know, it became kind of this weird collection of sacred objects almost. For a year, I kind of saw them as this other-- these empowered things.
我不知道，它几乎变成了一种奇怪的神圣物体收藏。有一年，我把它看作是其他——这些被赋予力量的东西。
Right. It's sort of like in the sci-fi movie when you come back from being back in time.
对。就像科幻电影里你从过去回来一样。
Right.
对。
And you reach in your pocket, and you still have the arrowhead or whatever.
你伸手进兜，你还有箭头之类的东西。
Right, exactly. Or when Tom Cruise wakes up in Eyes Wide Shut , and the mask from the night before is on his pillow. As much as I wanted to forget it, I woke up and those gift cards were there. It was like, oh, I guess that did happen.
对，没错。或者当汤姆·克鲁斯在《大开眼戒》中醒来，前一晚的面具就在他枕头上。尽管我想忘记它，但我醒来时，那些礼品卡还在那。心想，哦，我想那确实发生了。
Chris's response over time was different from Ghost of Pasha's. They came to appreciate the idea in their own way, but it just left Chris feeling vulnerable and a little paranoid. He hated the thought that all those strangers at the bar could just pop up again at any moment. One day, he was sitting on a bench in Union Square when a guy walked up to him and said, hey, Ted. He waved him off, but it was freaky.
随着时间的推移，克里斯的反应与“帕夏的幽灵”不同。他们以自己的方式体会到了那个想法，但这只让克里斯感到脆弱和有点偏执。他讨厌那种酒吧里的陌生人随时可能再次跳出来的想法。一天，他坐在联合广场的长椅上，一个人走过来对他说，嘿，泰德。他挥手让他走开，但这太诡异了。
It didn't help that his memory of the whole thing was a little hazy. For example, he didn't remember giving his phone number out to anyone that night. So you can imagine how he felt when Charlie called him a year later.
他对此事的记忆有点模糊，这没什么帮助。例如，他不记得那天晚上给任何人留过电话号码。所以你可以想象他一年后接到查理电话时的感觉。
And I said, hey, Ted. It's Charlie. How's it going? Your birthday's coming up in a few weeks. We want to know when you want to celebrate it. We want to throw you another party. Wanted to know what you wanted. Last year, we got you those Best Buy gift certificates. Do you want that again, or is there a different store? Give me a call back. And I gave him my number. And I didn't hear from him.
我说，嘿，泰德。我是查理。最近怎么样？你的生日再过几周就到了。我们想知道你什么时候想庆祝。我们想再给你办一个派对。想知道你想要什么。去年我们送了你百思买（Best Buy）的礼品卡。你还想要那个，还是别的店？给我回电话。我给了他我的号码。但我没收到他的回音。
And as it turns out, a friend of mine knows someone who's a bartender at Dempsy's, where we did Ted's birthday. And Ted is still a regular at that bar, I assume. And he told this bartender, he went up to her and said, "do you know the people who did that birthday thing to me last year?" And he said, "well, could you tell them to stop calling me. And if they're going to be coming around this bar, I'm gonna have to stop coming here."
事实证明，我的一个朋友认识邓普西酒吧的一个酒保，我们在那办的泰德的生日。泰德至今还是那个酒吧的常客，我想。他走到那个酒保面前说，“你知道去年给我办那个生日派对的人吗？”他说，“好吧，能不能告诉他们别再给我打电话了。如果他们再到这个酒吧来，我就得停止来这了。”
It really kind of broke my heart because it had been such a wonderful night and a wonderful experience for us. And it seemed like it had been a wonderful experience for him.
这真的伤了我的心，因为它对于我们来说是一个如此美好的夜晚和经历。看起来对于他来说也是一次美好的经历。
But is it? I mean, did it go well? Is it a success if a year later, Ted's story has changed?
但真的是吗？我的意思是，它进行得顺利吗？如果一年后泰德的故事改变了，这算成功吗？
Well, it does kind of-- that response definitely made me sad. But regardless of how he feels about it now, I do know that that night was awesome.
嗯，它确实——那个反应绝对让我感到难过。但不管他现在对此有何感受，我确实知道那天晚上很棒。
I kind of sound like the lead singer of Ghost of Pasha now. I want to tell him and kind of say the same things to him that that guy said to me, you know? Like, whatever you say, you had a blast that night.
我现在听起来有点像“帕夏的幽灵”的主唱。我想告诉他，并且像那个家伙对我说的那些话一样告诉他，你知道吗？不管你说什么，你那天晚上玩得很开心。
But he did. He did get his $300, and he did get completely drunk and make friends, even if for only a night. So that night, as it exists in my memory and in the memory of everybody who was there, was a success.
但他确实玩得很开心。他确实得到了那300美元，他确实喝得烂醉如泥，结交了朋友，即使只有一晚。所以那天晚上，正如它存在于我的记忆中以及当时在场所有人的记忆中一样，是成功的。
In the end, Chris did to Charlie which Charlie does so well to other people. He pretended to have an experience that he wasn't actually having. And Charlie thought the fake-out was real. And when he found out the truth, Charlie reacted the way other people do to him in that situation. He was sort of upset, a little hurt. And then he comforted himself by deciding that some part of the fake-out was real.
最后，克里斯对查理做了查理擅长对别人做的事。他假装经历了一个他实际上并未经历的体验。查理以为假象是真的。当他发现真相时，查理的反应和别人在那种情况下对他的反应一样。他有点难过，有点受伤。然后他决定假象中有一些部分是真实的，以此安慰自己。
And that's the danger of what Charlie does. He believes you'll enjoy sharing his fantasy world, whether you do or not. He asks you to leave your own reality and step into his, just like every crazy pantsless guy on the subway.
这就是查理行为的危险之处。他相信你会享受分享他的幻想世界，不管你是否享受。他请求你离开你自己的现实，步入他的世界，就像地铁上每一个疯狂的不穿裤子的人一样。
Jorge Just. We first aired this story in 2005. Ghosts of Pasha is still a band. In fact, they performed at an Improv Everywhere anniversary show recently. Milo, the lead singer, actually went out to join some missions as an agent with Improv Everywhere.
乔治·贾斯特。这个故事我们最早在2005年播出。“帕夏的幽灵”仍然是一个乐队。事实上，他们最近在“到处即兴表演”的周年演出上表演了。主唱米洛实际上甚至加入了“到处即兴表演”的团队参与了一些任务。
Coming up, when the most romantic possible thing you can do is also the least romantic possible thing you can do. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，当你能做的最浪漫的事情也是最不浪漫的事情时。芝加哥公共广播电台将在节目继续时在一分钟内告诉你。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, mind games. We've arrived at Act Three of our show-- Act Three, Lonely Hearts Club Band of One.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，当然，我们选择一个主题，为你带来关于这个主题的不同故事。今天的节目，心理游戏。我们已经到达了节目的第三幕——第三幕，单人寂寞心脏俱乐部乐队。
So a musician named David Berkeley was requested to play a concert that was a very mind-bendy, mind-game kind of experience, more than any other concert he ever played. Berkeley is a singer-songwriter on the indie music circuit. He gets showcased at South by Southwest. He's toured with Rufus Wainwright and Billy Bragg and Ben Folds, people like that.
一个叫大卫·伯克利的音乐家被要求举办一场音乐会，那是一场非常震撼心灵、非常具有心理游戏色彩的体验，超过了他以往举办过的任何音乐会。伯克利是独立音乐圈的一名创作歌手。他在“西南偏南”（South by Southwest）上亮相。他曾与鲁弗斯·温莱特、比利·布拉格和本·福尔兹等人一起巡演。
And though he's played tons of shows all over the country, this one was different, like I say. The idea is that he would fly to San Diego and play inside an apartment for just two people. And his goal would be to reunite the two as a couple. Now, of course, most songwriters wouldn't believe that their music has the power to move people's hearts. But I got to say, rarely does anybody get to test just how far that goes in such a clear-cut, goal-oriented way.
尽管他在全国各地举办过无数场演出，但正如我所说，这一场很特别。这个想法是他飞往圣地亚哥，在公寓里只为两个人表演。他的目标是让这对夫妻复合。当然，大多数创作歌手不会相信他们的音乐有力量去打动人们的心。但我得说，很少有人能以如此清晰、目标导向的方式测试它能达到什么程度。
The deal was the guy in the couple wanted to be together. In fact, he was the one who reached out to David in the first place. He and his girlfriend were on the rocks. And he was hoping that a private concert with David, maybe that would change her mind.
协议是，这对情侣中的男方想在一起。事实上，是他第一个联系大卫的。他和女友感情出现了裂痕。他希望通过大卫的一场私密音乐会，也许那能改变她的想法。
He had sent me a long email with kind of the battle plan, which the more I read, the more absurd it sort of seemed. The couple had either met at one of my concerts in California or their first date. I think their first date was at one of my concerts.
他发给我一封长邮件，说明了作战计划，我读得越多，就越觉得荒谬。这对情侣要么是在我在加州的音乐会上相遇的，要么是第一次约会。我想他们的第一次约会是在我的音乐会。
And he was gonna do everything he could to get her back. And I think that he decided that one huge gesture was probably what it would take. And so he planned this night from start to finish, which included going to their favorite restaurant, and the wine that they were going to order. And then the culmination was going to be the nightcap in their apartment, where I was going to pop through the door and sing them their concert.
他将尽一切努力挽回她。我想他决定，一个巨大的举动可能就是所需的。所以他从头到尾计划了那一晚，包括去他们最喜欢的餐厅，以及他们要点的酒。最后是公寓里的睡前酒，我将突然穿门而入，为他们唱音乐会。
And then he just sort of gave me the plan for how I was going to sneak into the apartment without them knowing, and how I was going to have to actually sneak into the garage, which literally involved me following a car in and trying to get through the gate before the gate closed and then up a back elevator onto the eighth floor, where I would then knock on his apartment door.
然后他给了我计划，关于我如何在他们不知情的情况下溜进公寓，以及我如何真正溜进车库，这实际上涉及我跟着一辆车进去，试图在闸门关闭前穿过，然后上一部后部电梯到八楼，然后敲他的公寓门。
Not to ask a kind of dumb question, but couldn't he just send you a key?
不是为了问这种愚蠢的问题，但他不能直接给你寄把钥匙吗？
Yeah. I guess that didn't cross his or my mind. But yeah, he should have. And I was actually nervous. I play a lot of concerts, and rarely have I been nervous like this.
是的。我想这没在他或我的脑海中闪过。但确实，他应该这样做。我当时其实很紧张。我举办过很多音乐会，但像这样紧张的时候很少。
And I guess it was because I had no idea what I was walking into. And I was about to knock on the door, and I started to think about, what is she going to do when I walk in? And I guess I expected that she was-- despite feeling like things weren't going well, I thought she was going to be really excited to see me. And she would-- I don't know what. She would give me a hug, or she would laugh, or something like that.
我想是因为我不知道我要走进什么。我就要敲门了，我开始想，我走进去时她会做什么？我想，尽管感觉事情进展不顺利，但我以为她会非常兴奋看到我。她会——不知道做什么。她会拥抱我，或者她会笑，之类的。
And in fact, I opened the door, and she just sort of kind of crumpled. She sort of collapsed. Her head kind of fell into her hands, and I think she might have said, I can't believe you did this. He shouldn't have done this.
事实上，我打开门，她只是——萎缩了。她崩溃了。她的头有点埋进手里，我想她可能说了，我不相信你做了这种事。他不该这样做。
And it was hard for me, at this point, not to take that a little personally, you know? Because without sort of knowing it, I had kind of joined sides with this guy. I was on his team. We were coming in to do a job.
这一刻，我很难不把它个人化，你知道吗？因为在不知情的情况下，我已经站到了那个家伙那边。我是他那队的。我们进来做一项工作。
OK. So what do you do?
好的。那么你该做什么？
I think I said something like, hi. I thought I might play you a few songs. And it just felt gross. I felt, why was I even here? And the guy asked me if I wanted to sit or stand, which I normally stand when I perform. But that seemed completely absurd to me, that I was going to stand and perform to these two people in their living room. So I said I would sit. And he pulled a chair up for me.
我想我说了些类似“嗨”的话。我想我或许可以为你唱几首歌。但这感觉真恶心。我觉得，我为什么在这儿？那个人问我是想坐还是站，我通常表演时是站着的。但这对我来说完全荒谬，我将要站在他们的客厅里为这两个人表演。所以我说我想坐。他为我拉了一把椅子。
And I was across a small coffee table from them. And they sat down on the couch. And I sat down in my chair, and I started to play.
我就坐在小咖啡桌对面。他们坐在沙发上。我坐在椅子上，开始弹奏。
And so they're on the couch. And are they sitting close together?
所以他们在沙发上。他们坐得很近吗？
God, no. I think it was just a three-cushion couch, and they were on the left and the right cushions. And there was a big cushion in between.
天哪，不。那只是个三座沙发，他们坐在左右两端的靠垫上。中间隔着一个大靠垫。
Now, you have your guitar there. You and I are speaking to each other from different locations. You want to just play a couple lines of the song so we have a sense of what this was?
现在，你有吉他在那。你和我从不同地点通话。你想弹几句那首歌，让我们对那是什么有个概念吗？
Let me just tune real quick.
让我快速调一下音。
[TUNING GUITAR]
[调吉他音]
OK.
好的。
[PLAYING GUITAR]
[弹吉他]
I should stop right there because I got about that far in the song and glanced up. And that was enough for her to recognize the song. And she started to cry, which wasn't what I had hoped would happen.
我应该在那停下，因为我弹到那儿，抬头看了一眼。她已经认出那首歌了。她开始哭，那不是我希望发生的事。
[PLAYING GUITAR]
[弹吉他]
(SINGING) A couple on a bridge, a stone bridge in some European town. After all the years, I see we all fall down. The knock at the front door, the crack in the wall.
(唱歌) 欧洲某城镇的一座石桥上的一对情侣。多年以后，我看到我们都倒下了。敲前门的声音，墙上的裂缝。
And right when I sang that part of the chorus-- the knock on the front door-- it seemed like suddenly, I was actually singing a song that was the story of this night.
就在我唱到合唱的那部分时——敲前门的声音——仿佛突然间，我真的在唱一首讲述那个晚上故事的歌。
Yeah, yeah. This is a song about a couple for whom things are not going very well.
对，对。这是一首关于一对事情进展不太顺利的情侣的歌。
Yeah. And why I didn't know that and think about that before I started to play it, I don't know. But it was too late. And this happens at times in a performance, where you recognize you've made the wrong choice of a song. And you can never really go back. I had to just barrel through.
是的。我为什么在弹奏之前没有意识到并想到这一点，我不知道。但太迟了。这种事在演出时偶尔发生，当你意识到你选错了歌。你永远无法回头。我只能硬着头皮演完。
And so where do you go? What do you play next? What do you do?
那么接下来去哪？你接着弹什么？你做什么？
Well, I think I played a song that was a story song that was more lighthearted. And I got through that. But the night wasn't getting any easier. And also, you have to understand that after a song finishes, two people kind of clapping a couple of times after you finish a song, it sounds really, really depressing.
嗯，我想我弹了一首故事歌，比较轻松。我演完了那首。但那一晚并没有变得更容易。而且你必须明白，歌曲结束后，两个人啪啪啪拍几下手，听起来真的很让人沮丧。
I guess I didn't really stop to think about the fact that the song would end, and they would either have to clap or not.
我想我当时没停下来思考，歌曲会结束，他们要么鼓掌要么不鼓掌。
Well, that's why this was so weird, because the time in between the songs became as painful as the songs themselves.
嗯，这就是为什么它如此诡异，因为歌曲之间的间歇变得和歌曲本身一样痛苦。
And so what do you do to try to turn the situation around?
那么你做什么来试图扭转局面？
Well, let me first say that, as I'm singing that song, right after I sang the first lyric, I regretted the choice. And I started thinking ahead. And when I started racing through in my mind the other songs that I was going to be able to play this night, I started to get really scared because I realized that not only might it not have been a good idea to hire a musician to come across the country and sing to get back your girl, but I was probably the wrong musician to have hired.
嗯，首先说一下，我在唱那首歌时，唱完第一句歌词后，我就后悔了这个选择。我开始向前看。当我脑子里快速过一遍那天晚上我能弹的其他歌时，我开始感到非常害怕，因为我意识到，雇一个音乐家跨越全国来唱歌挽回女友不仅可能不是个好主意，而且我可能还雇错了音乐家。
Because of your melancholic repertoire.
因为你那忧郁的曲库。
Exactly. And he knew this because he knows my music. So maybe on the third or fourth song I played, the song "Straw Man," which is one of the ones that he had asked for-- and I'll play a little bit of it.
没错。他知道这一点，因为他了解我的音乐。所以可能在我弹的第三或第四首歌《稻草人》（Straw Man）时，这是他点名要的一首——我会弹一点点。
[PLAYING GUITAR]
[弹吉他]
(SINGING) Never quite so clean, she makes the world around me seem lavender and wintergreen when we're side by side.
(唱歌) 从未如此干净，当我们在彼此身边时，她让周围的世界看起来像薰衣草和冬青。
And that chorus repeats several times. And after about the second chorus, I looked up, and I felt like she softened a little bit. And it seemed like the song was doing a little bit more of its job.
那个合唱重复了好几次。唱到第二次合唱后，我抬头看，感觉她软化了一点。看起来这首歌确实发挥了一点作用。
And by the end of the song, it really did feel like it had changed something in the room. And she kind of was sitting up a little straighter, maybe. And she was looking at me more. And I even kind of saw her look at him a little and give a little smile. And that was a tiny gesture, but it was so good to see.
歌曲结束时，确实感觉房间里发生了改变。她坐直了一些。她看我看得更多了。我甚至看到她看了看他，给了一个小微笑。那是个微小的举动，但很高兴能看到。
And so from there, was it better?
从那时起，情况好点了吗？
Well, so then we got on a little bit of a roll. But with each song, and even smaller increments, with each verse, it seemed like they were symbolically and literally moving closer together. And in fact, by maybe song five or six, they actually were sitting next to each other.
嗯，后来我们进入了一点状态。但每弹一首歌，甚至更小的增量，每一段歌词，他们似乎在象征意义和字面意义上都靠得更近了。事实上，到大概第五或第六首歌时，他们真的坐在了一起。
And I couldn't believe it. I couldn't believe it. I really didn't think there was any chance. And certainly from the beginning of the night till that point, there seemed like there was zero chance.
我无法相信。我无法相信。我真的不觉得有任何机会。从那一晚开始到那一刻，看起来似乎完全没机会了。
But they started holding hands. And at one point in a song, she lay her head on his shoulder. So it's working. And I play a song that actually, they kiss. And that was a shock. And at that point, I thought, this is it. We've done it. I wanted to slap the guy's hand. I felt great.
但他们开始牵手。在某一首歌里，她把头靠在他肩上。所以奏效了。我弹了一首歌，他们甚至亲吻了。那是个震惊。那一刻我想，就是这个。我们做到了。我想拍拍那个人的手。我感觉棒极了。
But the mood had changed, but it was still painfully awkward and, if anything, more so now because I was now right across the coffee table from a couple who's making out as I'm singing. And now it felt totally wrong that I was there, just for different reasons. At one point, they kissed, and I locked eyes with her right as they're kissing. And we both looked away immediately, but it happened.
但心情变了，依然痛苦地尴尬，如果说有什么改变的话，现在更尴尬了，因为我正坐在一个正亲热的情侣面前弹唱。现在我在这儿感觉完全不对劲，只是原因变了。在某一刻，他们亲吻时，我正好和她目光相接。我们立刻避开了，但还是发生了。
And at one point, he and I met eyes at just a really badly-timed moment, where he was giving her one of these looks like, I'm your man. And I will be there for you forever. And we'll have beautiful children together. And there I am. And he and I are looking at each other suddenly for a second, but a very, very bad second of my life.
在某一刻，我和他正好在一个时机很糟的时刻对上了眼，他给她那种眼神，仿佛在说，我是你的人。我会永远为你守候。我们会生下漂亮的孩子。而我正在那儿。我和他突然看了一眼对方，一秒钟，但我人生中最糟糕的一秒。
So things move from horrible to exuberant to straight out creepy, it sounds like.
听起来事情从恐怖变为狂喜，再到纯粹的诡异。
I think that's fair. But at least when I'm singing, I can just sort of get lost in the fact that the music is sort of working for them. And so as I finish the concert, she hugs me, and he walks me out of the apartment and down to the elevator. I get to take the main elevator down this time.
我认为很中肯。但至少当我唱歌时，我可以沉浸在音乐对他们确实奏效了的事实中。所以当我结束音乐会时，她拥抱了我，他把我送出公寓，下到电梯。这次我终于可以坐主电梯下去了。
And he tells me something to the effect of, you never know how things are going to work out. But I think that you may have been the tipping point tonight. And that felt great. I was so happy.
他告诉我，你永远不知道事情会如何发展。但我认为今晚你可能是转折点。感觉棒极了。我太高兴了。
Right. Your music brought these people together.
对。你的音乐把这些人撮合到了一起。
Brought them together in the first place, maybe, brought them back together now. It was perfect. Even when I had tried to serenade ex-girlfriends to get them back directly, that hadn't worked.
可能一开始把他们撮合在一起，现在又把他们撮合回来。太完美了。即使当我试图弹小夜曲挽回前女友时，也都没奏效过。
A few months after all this, David Berkeley was back in California doing a show in Los Angeles, and the guy emailed him, asking if David would give him two spots on the guest list. But the guy did not bring the girl. He came with a buddy.
所有这一切发生几个月后，大卫·伯克利回到加州在洛杉矶表演，那个家伙发邮件给他，问大卫是否能在嘉宾名单上给他两个位置。但那家伙没带那个女孩。他带着个朋友来的。
And he told David afterwards that things didn't work out. Incredibly, David says that he would do this all over again if somebody else asked him to do it. And as for the guy-- OK, after this failure, would he try another concert in his apartment?
事后他告诉大卫，事情没成。不可思议的是，大卫说，如果别人再让他做一次，他还会做。至于那个家伙——好吧，在这次失败后，他还会尝试在公寓里举办另一场音乐会吗？
I know he would. And in fact, I know that he would do it again with me because he's made that clear.
我知道他会。事实上，我知道他还会找我做这件事，因为他已经表现得很清楚了。
What?
什么？
He's made it clear that if he has another girl, he hopes the situation will arise where he can have me come and do another serenade.
他表现得很清楚，如果他有了另一个女孩，他希望出现那种可以让我去为她唱小夜曲的情况。
But wait, would you go?
但等等，你会去吗？
What would be funny is that my exclusive knowledge of him is related to this other episode that we wouldn't be able to talk about, this other girl where I did the same thing. And of course, the new girl isn't going to want to know about the old girl and is certainly not going to want to know that he did the same trick.
好笑的是，我对他的独家了解与我们无法谈论的另一段插曲有关，另一女孩，我做了同样的事。当然，新女孩不想知道旧女孩的事，更不想知道他用了同样的诡计。
Yeah. Yeah, I was just thinking that. It definitely takes the romantic idealism off the whole thing.
是的。是的，我刚才也在想那个。这绝对让整个事情失去了浪漫的理想色彩。
Yeah. Then it starts to get bizarre in a whole other way because now I'm sort of his guy. And I'm not sure about that.
是的。那样就开始变得非常怪异了，因为现在我是他的专属人选。我不确定这件事。
David Berkeley. He's recently released a book of 10 short stories called The Free Brontosaurus and an accompanying album, 10 songs called Cardboard Box. This story was produced with the help of Marshall Lewy.
大卫·伯克利。他最近出版了一本包含10个短篇小说的书《自由雷龙》（The Free Brontosaurus），以及一张配套专辑，包含10首歌《硬纸板盒》（Cardboard Box）。这个故事是在马歇尔·路易的帮助下制作的。
Well, our program was produced today by Jane Marie and myself with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for today's show, Julie Snyder. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Production help from Lyra Smith. Our website, thisamericanlife.org.
我们的节目今天由简·玛丽和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、戴安·库克、温迪·多尔、莎拉·柯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。今天节目的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。制作帮助来自莱拉·史密斯。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Special thanks, as always, to our co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who reminds me all the time--
《美国生活》由公共广播电台交换平台（PRX）分发至各公共广播电台。一如既往，特别感谢我们的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生，他一直提醒我——
I'm your man, and I will be there for you forever. And we'll have beautiful children together.
我是你的人，我会永远为你守候。我们会生下漂亮的孩子。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周会有更多《美国生活》的故事。